today we're talking about anthos on AWS
supporting health care providers and
Google cloud training a mark and welcome
to this week when cloud where we serve
you the lowest latency news from the
safety of home Anthes was announced with
an ambitious goal to enable portability
for applications across your multi cloud
or hybrid infrastructure over the past
year we've been working hard on
expanding support for multi cloud and
we've just graduated AWS support -
generally available will continue to
provide flexible cloud computing
solutions so that your business can grow
and adapt to whatever comes its way as
the healthcare industry is pushed to its
limits we're focusing on offering
support and solutions wherever we can
from offering HIPAA compliant telehealth
services with Google meat to providing
Google cloud research credits and
hosting a free repository of public
healthcare data sets and finally we've
released our cloud healthcare API is
generally available to help
organizations ingest and manage key data
from a variety of systems cloud spanner
provides a scaleable multi version
database with relational semantics we've
just introduced managed backup restore
to provide data protection with minimal
management overhead these restore czar
optimized for data access meaning that
you can access terabytes of restored
data within minutes of a failure
check out the post to learn more and to
see other new features in spanner when
it comes to Google cloud training we
focused on creating content for all
learning styles from self-paced courses
to instructor led workshops while
in-person learning isn't possible right
now we're focusing on creating virtual
classrooms
check out cloud trading to learn more
about enrolling in a virtual class and
to see all of the courses we offer if
you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link have any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us we'll see
you in the cloud
you